it's almost like YouTube hates trans
people too or they're I think it comes
down to
YouTube really doesn't care they're just
like whatever makes us money I literally
don't care if Dylan Mulvaney is the
worst example of of of a person in media
who is insulting women and trans people
at the same time if it makes us money
just take the action well it's also the
phrase you said I think is key for a lot
of women and that is a very insulting
portrayal of a quote-unquote woman right
like think about the very first days of
girlhood video where sitting behind the
keyboard being like okay my first day of
being a woman I wrote an angry email
that I didn't send I cried a couple of
times I all these the very misogynistic
stereotypes of of a woman I saw that and
I was like excuse me I've been a woman
for 33 years I haven't done any of that
but you know what people who hate women
accuse women accuse women of behaving
like that